about. >> That sounds right David. There are sort of several other things to
note here. What is the last sentence that has two verbs in it? Decided and
go. You'll see in a minute, how we can deal with sentences or
stories that have multiple verbs in them. Second, you are right in
that it is not always very easy to decide which is the best primitive action for
capturing the meaning of a particular verb here.
So the verb here was pushed, and the reason David propelled or
moved object is because in propulsion the body is in some sense in
contact with the particular object that is getting moved. Now we are not sure
inherently detailed specification of each of one of these primitive actions. But
I can tell you that the readings at the end do give them in detail